yeah and i think the big question is
you know and and i keep wondering this
about sort of the long-term
way that this season is going to go mike
because and i realize i'm taking a
little bit of a 180 but i did not want
to exit this show without getting your
opinion on this
if the nfl chooses chooses to add a week
18
and i think they really do not want to
do that okay but if they choose to do a
week 18
how much does that impact the number one
seed in the nfc and the number one seed
in the afc and i asked the question
because the number one seeds you work
all year you work your rear end off to
be the number one seed can you imagine
if your reward is oh by the way you're
off for three weeks
i mean
that's i've got there's a lot of unfair
things about this year
go ahead i've got a solution the
solution comes from our mutual friend
chris mad dog russo i was on him with
him the other day and i was blown away
by the simplicity of this and it's one
of those things where
damn it i wish i thought of it
his idea is
if you have a week 18
if you have a makeup week
you make that week 17
and you bump week 17
to week 18.
so you don't have three weeks for the
team that that that earns the buy in
each conference and your season still
has that crescendo of action with
everyone playing on sunday and we figure
out all the seating and all the playoff
teams so there the week 18 is really
week 17
and the makeup week is week 17. what do
you think of that
well i guess i would ask two questions
what if there's only three games in week
18
and
which becomes week 17.
so
it's january 3rd you turn on the tv
and are you saying that
that
even teams that have nothing to play for
have this buy and now they got to hang
around for an extra week and i'm not
saying hey look i heard this the other
day mike and i actually think that it
has a lot of merit so i'm not killing it
all i'm saying is that the practical
parts of it are a little bit weird you
know you wake up on sunday morning
january 3rd
in what should be a really big day of
football you're reaching a crescendo and
it's a lead balloon you got three games
and who knows what if a couple of these
games are
jets
dolphins
you know or
you know games that literally have no
meaning whatsoever so i don't know it's
interesting and i don't i don't dismiss
it out of hand
but i think that it's certainly not
ideal
well and here's the other thing too
there's you've got some flexibility with
what you can do because fans aren't
going to be at most of these games you
can bump games around you can we're
already seeing them move the chess
pieces willy-nilly
if it gets to the point where there are
multiple games that are postponed that
would suggest we've reached a point
where
it's time to break glass in event of
emergency and put all the teams in home
market bubbles like if we get to the
point where there's that you know two
three four five six games that have to
be rescheduled that means we've had more
outbreaks that means they've been unable
to fix it just by moving games to monday
or tuesday or or whenever they can fit
them in
so
if you're in a bubble
at that point i think what you could do
is you could do the makeup games
whenever you want you could do the
makeup games first week of december if
you want to and push everything back a
week so those games that would otherwise
seem meaningless if you tack them on at
the end of the season to the teams that
are done or if you do them in week 17
when it's the the dolphins or the jets
and that you do it in early december
most teams are still alive in early
december so there's different places you
can drop the makeup week and if you are
in a bubble and the bubble's working you
don't have to worry about factoring in
the possibility of other games being
postponed you can be confident that
you're going to pull it off so
i i think that i hope it doesn't come to
it
but if it does
i think that i agree with
the mad dog that
we shouldn't just tack them on to the
end of the season
that we should still find a way that the
final sunday of the season whenever it
is is still the same final sunday of the
season that it always is with everyone
playing on the same day so we'll see how
that all plays out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports